hello
thank you so much hannah and it's a huge
pleasure to be here thanks to
intelligence square
all the team there i think worked very
hard to bring this event uh together
and it's a particular pleasure to be
able to do that because we have uh an
old friend of
intelligence squared and i have to say
an old friend of mine in
the chair today it is of course
professor neil ferguson who
is one of the best known historians
working in the world really today
he is currently a senior fellow at the
hoover institution
at stanford university although as i
think we may gather in the conversation
he has uh been more locationally varied
during the course of the
last year he's also senior faculty
fellow at the belfast center for science
and international affairs
at harvard university and he's the
author of 16 books
and counting one must say they include
classics such as the pity of war
the house of rothschild empire
civilization
and the first part of a definitive
biography of henry kissinger
the first half called the idealist and
we're very much looking forward i think
to to part two
recently he also published the square
and the tower
he writes a column for bloomberg opinion
and he's the founder and managing
director of the advisory firm
green mantle llc and
the most recent of that long run of
books
is the one that hannah just mentioned
doom the politics of catastrophe
and i'm looking forward very much to
talking about that with neil and also
with all of you
who have joined us tonight for this
event
we're going to have an hour together for
the first half an hour or so neil and i
will be in conversation
and then in the second half we will be
taking your questions
and you don't have to wait till the half
hour is over to start asking them please
use the question
function which you can find on the
bottom of your screen the ask
question button just click it pop in
your question if you'd like to put in
your name and where you're located
please
do that if you'd rather ask anonymously
that's absolutely fine
as well uh but please make sure whatever
you do you press the send button
otherwise we will not receive
your question and won't be able to put
it to our speaker today
so i hope that is all clear and also if
you are a tweeter please make sure that
at all times you are uh tweeting
iq2 as well that will be fantastic if
you were
to join us in that way also so i think
high time
we got to the uncompromisingly uh termed
doom and find out what exactly the
politics of catastrophe
are um neil um it's a great pleasure to
be
uh with you this evening um i have to
say you've got a fantastically
sort of undo like setting behind you
there you look like you're in my
circumstances at the moment i
i hope that actually accurately reflects
where you are at the moment
well thank you rana it's a pleasure to
join you and everybody at intelligence
squared
uh i am in california and california
gives the impression uh of being
paradise
uh except that it bursts into flames
annually uh and each year on a larger
scale and
on a wider extent so while it may look
like
uh paradise and i'm sure if it's still
hailing
in oxford it does uh in reality i'm in a
very combustible
neck of the woods i'm also a very short
distance away from one of the great
fault lines
at san andreas fault and at some point
there'll be an absolutely
huge earthquake here i hope not during
this
broadcast so there are lots of ways in
which disaster looms even when
things look absolutely idyllic as that i
admit they do behind me
well let's say not so much paradise lost
as paradise possibly imploding but we
very much hope that we'll hold off from
that in the next
uh hour or so um the book
is about covert amongst other things and
it's of course not a coincidence that
it's uh come out
during the middle of this current
pandemic and we will of course talk
about that
but it's about much more than that as
well the bigger question of why some
societies and some types of political
systems
respond better than others to
catastrophe and
without having you spill the beans at
the beginning i am going to ask you to
spill the beans a little bit at this
point
what's the overall thesis of the book
what is the answer to the question about
what kind of societies do respond better
to catastrophes of all sorts
well the thesis is that disasters
whether they're natural
or man-made are all to some extent
politically mediated it's a function of
politics
uh how great the excess mortality gets
to be
when a novel pathogen suddenly sweeps
the world
uh and so that's part one of my answer
that's that's why the subtitle is
is important even the things that we
think of as completely
natural uh like a pandemic uh in fact
require politics to become disastrous
because
covert wasn't disastrous everywhere and
the same applies when you look at all
of the great disasters in history
including including wars
uh and wars can inflict devastating
casualties uh on a country and the
country can
hold together or relatively mild uh
impacts can somehow lead to collapse
there's no straightforward correlation
in other words between the body count
and the resilience of a society and what
interests me
is that there are clearly in history
some societies that are remarkably
resilient can cope with successive
disasters of of multiple forms and still
carry on
functioning and this seems to be partly
to do with state competence state
structure and how
the institutions of the state function
uh in the face of disaster but it's also
to do with social cohesion i think and
how far
a society hangs together when there's an
enormous
stress test going on so that that's
broadly speaking the
the overall argument uh i haven't told
you the answer
i think the answer is that societies
need to be and institutions need to be
quite nimble it's it's flexibility of
response that seems to me to be
the key and often speed of response
and societies that look on paper to be
tremendously well prepared
for disaster with 36 page reports of
pandemic preparedness
can turn out not to be because they've
got an excessively rigid approach
to crisis management and that that i
think is the the answer to the question
that it is
much better to be a resilient
nimble rapid responder rather than to be
kind of
over prepped bureaucracy when when
disaster strikes
just to follow up on that thought term
neil one word that you left out of that
string of adjectives was democratic and
reading having read the book it doesn't
seem to me that you necessarily
feel that the argument is about
democratic systems versus
authoritarian ones in terms of dealing
with the most recent pandemic
is that is that not a factor
particularly i don't think it is i mean
a lot of
of the kind of naive commentary last
year
uh said oh look how badly the
democracies are handling this and look
how well
china has handled it with its uh
draconian lockdown
i thought that was a complete misreading
of what was happening a
the disaster had begun in the chinese
system because rather
as after chernobyl there had been lies
and
uh and deceptions and delays which
caused the the crisis to get much
much worse but also the draconian
lockdown that china imposed on itself in
late january wasn't the optimal solution
the optimal
solution was what taiwan did a democracy
and what south korea
did a democracy that those were the
countries that rapidly tested large
numbers of people and
used contact tracing to figure out who
might have been infected and then
quarantined or isolated the people who
were
so that the best performances came from
democracies and the worst performances
came
from democracies a lot of naive
generalizations also followed the form
populist leaders are to blame for
disastrous excess mortality well
in some countries they certainly didn't
help matters but there were plenty of
countries that had non-populous leaders
that did even worse
belgium did terribly well terribly badly
last year
and its prime minister for most of the
year was a liberal woman sophie wilmers
peru
has had about the worst excess mortality
and it's not a populist
who was running uh peru last year so i i
kind of came to realize as i
picked my way through some of the
commentary last year how tempting it is
to jump
to conclusions about which political
system is doing
best it's a lot more complicated than
that and
you've raised in my mind a really
important point that the book delves
into
and that's a martial sen's argument
about famines
and i'm sure you're going to ask me
about that because it's it's right up
your street as a historian of of china
amateur sends path-breaking work on on
famine
argued that ultimately one shouldn't
think of a famine as a natural disaster
that it was essentially a political
failure and in one essay he argued that
democracy
he had india in mind would would never
have tolerated the kind of famines that
mao's china
suffered largely as a consequence of the
crazy policies that that mao
pursued in in the 1950s and
i i was tremendously impressed by that
argument when i first encountered it but
when i was writing doom
i find myself saying well if if that's
true of famines
is it shouldn't it be true of all
disasters and then i began to realize
that it
might not actually be true of all
disasters and it doesn't seem to have
been true
of this one of the of the covert 19
pandemic
well it quite right now that we will
come back to some of those questions of
how
the world outside the west and indeed
china have dealt with these questions so
we'll put a pause on that but but one
that we will certainly come back to
before we do that though i want to dive
into some of the historical examples
that you give
in the book and just because most
commentary which looks at the history
has been looking at the 1918-19
flew pandemic and yeah that is very very
important i want to choose one of the
other
pandemics that you look at and it's one
that's known but not as well remembered
the so-called asian flu those days are
still allowed to give geographical
locations to
diseases the asian flu of 1957
and you look at it from the point of
view of the administration then of
president eisenhower
uh you know the post-war era in the
united states when we think of
actually as a time of prosperity one
when america was beginning to rise
or had risen to the global power in the
cold war but looked at through the lens
of that particular disease you tell a
somewhat different story
yes i i got very interested in 1957 58
precisely because i hadn't known about
it before and indeed no one had ever
mentioned it to me until last year when
my good friend nicholas christakis one
of the world's leading authorities
on pandemics and network science
mentioned it
i think in a tweet my ears as it were
pricked up
in 5758 the world was hit by a
pandemic a new strain of influenza
comparable in scale to covert 19. much
more
like it than 1980 1918-19 the so-called
spanish
influenza which was a devastating
disaster killed about 39
million people if if if something like
that happened with our
global population you would be looking
at a death toll in the
hundreds of millions uh but 1957 58 uh
killed about the same proportion of the
world's population as covert has
so far which is around about 0.04
percent
uh it's not the same disaster
it wasn't as big a disaster in the
united states as covert has been but
globally it seems about in the right
ballpark
and also interestingly unlike covert
uh the the asian flu of 5758 killed a
lot of young people
and affected the very young as much as
the very old and it also affected
and caused a great deal of of illness
and mortality amongst
teenagers so if you do the calculation
on
life year's loss considering that 80
percent of the americans who've died of
covert have been over 65
actually about roughly the same number
of life years
were lost maybe a bit less in 57 58 so
what's interesting about this
what is interesting is the completely
different reaction of the eisenhower
administration
and american society at large to this
disaster
uh there is no lock down uh schools are
not closed
uh there isn't even a state of emergency
the public health officials know
that the virus is going to sweep through
the country and and cause excess
mortality but they
they tell the president that we can't
really stop this and so we're just going
to focus all our efforts on finding a
vaccine
and remarkably because we've been
telling ourselves that what happened
last year was a
a feat of medical science without
precedent well unfortunately that's not
true there was a precedent
maurice hillman found a vaccine against
the spanish flu
in just a matter of months and not only
found it but the earth government was
able to deploy it
even faster than we've deployed the kovy
covert vaccines
so it's a remarkable story more i think
for
the very different way in which uh
government and society
reacted in in 2020 as compared with the
way they reacted in 1957.
well one of the other things that i
think was fascinating to me about the
story and i knew
you know very little about the the
events uh as well so it was it was a
real
eye-opener was the way in which as you
point out
attitudes towards risk were also rather
different at that point
one of the things that in many ways
quite rightly that has happened during
the most recent pandemic
is that there has been a pretty strong
precautionary principle certainly
amongst
developed countries in uh europe in
north america and
those sorts of uh of areas you could
argue actually the same about china i
suppose in the grounds that
massive brutal crackdowns are
precautionary if if nothing else
whereas the impression i get from you
know what you say about
that 1950s period is that it's an era
when
polio is still you know running pretty
rampant uh
amongst the the the the youth of that
country that we had a president
just a decade before president roosevelt
who had suffered polio in
his youth at the same time of course
this is still a generation just a year
out of the most devastating global war
and overall do you think i mean in a way
that's become rather politically
incorrect for
for uncertain reasons perhaps in our
most recent pandemic a lot of people
were there simply saying well you know a
lot of people will get this
a lot of people will die and that's just
the way that the world works
i think it's clear from talking to to
people who lived through it that that
was
the mentality then people actually
worried more about polio in the 50s than
they worried about influenza though they
probably should have worried more about
influenza
in terms of its uh its overall mortality
uh that they had been through not only
world war ii but the korean war
there was a sense that life uh was bound
to deal you
uh some bad hands and uh
this was just something you had to take
in your stride but since i first started
writing about this i
published a paper about it last year
when i first was working on it
i've had lots of response from people
who lived through it including a friend
who said
i actually had the biggest worst illness
of my life at the age of 10
during that pandemic and he said and you
know
what strikes me looking back is is how
we just got on with life
and i've heard that from many many
americans who who recollect the pandemic
but but recollect also the the way in
which people
was stoical about it and clearly that
wasn't what happened
in 2020 in 2020 there was an
extraordinary polarization
along political lines in a way that's
completely unrecognizable because
in the 1950s a public health crisis was
a public health crisis you didn't
politicize it nobody attempted to do
that
in 2020 every issue from the virus
itself
to mask wearing to vaccination became
politicized
and democrats broadly speaking were
extremely risk averse
exaggerated the the risk that they faced
personally
and republicans were completely the
opposite and understated the risk
uh that they faced so that's how one of
the ways at least in which
in in which the united states has
changed by the way
as this is likely a mostly british
audience 5758 was not
especially bad although it did affect
the united kingdom 1951 was much worse
now and the 1951 influenza really shows
up if you look at the
long-run u.s uk mortality data
it's actually one of the worst years in
the past century or so
for high mortality along with 1918
uh 1940 and and 2020
and almost nobody remembers the 1951
influenza
uh pandemic unless you were kind of
elderly liverpudlian because liverpool
had an especially torrid time of it
in that year and it's a reminder that
quite often things which are utterly
devastating at the time can sometimes
really fade from memory quite quickly in
certain ways although they turn up
in slightly different sorts of ways i
mean one of the notes that i really
liked about
the 1919 uh pandemic that you talked
about
was the fact that it affected the
culture of the 1920s and i'm thinking
here particularly of
a jazz song i was not previously aware
of by huey smith called
rocking pneumonia and the boogie woogie
flu
i must say that's not on my list of of
curtfile classics but maybe you've been
spinning it uh in your uh pandemic
hideaway there really
well actually rana the rock and
pneumonia in the boogie boogie floor was
a 1957
hit um it's uh
it's actually and it's a rather a good
number made made the charts though
not quite up there without elvis's uh
teddy bear which was one of the big hits
of
of that year uh but but i think the
interesting thing about the song is that
it makes light
of a disease that was very threatening
to teenagers
one of the points about this is that
teenagers were the most gregarious
people
uh in america in the 1950s and they were
probably the most gregarious people in
in the world because this was the age of
uh of
of just teenage heaven non-stop
uh parties uh camps
it seems to me that being a teenager in
1950s america
was probably more fun than being human
had ever been before
certainly looking at the movies from
that time you get the impression that
that was so and yet they were all
running tremendous risk by being so
convivial in 1957-58
and yet to the boogie woogie blues also
the boogie-woogie flu is probably
an exception on the grounds that most
teenagers if they were imbibing popular
culture would be more worried about
being smashed up in an automobile
accident like james dean
they were less worried particularly
about sniffling themselves to uh to an
early grave
and that's that's something that that
there hasn't been nearly as much of in
the in the last year where even the
british
sense of humor has seemed to falter uh
in the face of
of excess mortality and that probably
has something to do with the fact that
people are still very close to in this
country
over a hundred thousand deaths and it
will take time to come past that
we're going to carry on a discussion but
just a reminder to our audience please
do join in as well do send in those
questions
do tweet on iq2 we're very keen to
get your questions for neil about not
just covert but also the wider question
of the politics of catastrophe and let
me
move on if i may to take up some of the
wider ideas that you put forward in the
book
um some of which i think drawn on
previous work that you've done which
talk about
how we learn from history or don't
because you do use the phrase
failure to learn for history as one of
several points that you make about what
we should try and put forward but
you know we all know that history is not
a simple textbook which you can simply
uh draw that's political science no not
really he says uh apologizing to any
political scientists in the audience
um but what does it mean in practice to
learn
from history whether it's this
particular catastrophe or maybe maybe
another one how would you do it in
practice
well i've been beating the drum for
applied history for some
years now in the belief that certainly
in the united states
far too little regard is paid uh
in the government to the lessons that
can be learnt
uh from from past experience now i'm not
saying this is easy
but one must at least try and i think
the council of despair i remember being
given at oxford
as an undergraduate oh you can't learn
lessons from history that's journalism
dear boy
that council of despair has actually led
to a kind of uh fatalism
uh and a neglect of of the things that
can
be learned i'll give a concrete example
i think that
one of the big mistakes that was made by
the public health bureaucracies in most
western countries was not to pay much
attention
to what had happened in the cases of
sars and mars
which were both coronav virus uh
outbreaks
they didn't become uh global because uh
the the virus was so lethal that it
couldn't really spread very far
uh but that was something that the
taiwanese and the south koreans studied
pretty closely and and we didn't
uh so there's a clearing example there
if i look back to work that i did uh in
the ascent of money on
financial crises it was staggering to me
how few people
when the financial crisis began in 2008
had any real understanding
of the financial crisis the biggest
previous financial crisis of
of 1929 to 32. so
learning from history doesn't give you a
kind of cookbook recipe
this is what you do in case of a
pandemic but i think if once
aware of past disasters uh one has a
sense of at least some of the
pitfalls that policymakers can fall into
larry brilliant gave a wonderful ted
talk he's an epidemiologist based here
in the u.s
back in i think 2005 where he said the
key to pandemics and he'd worked on the
eradication
of smallpox the key said is early
detection
and early action that's the real lesson
of of of the modern pandemic and
and and that lesson was was completely
lost as far as i can see on
on the public health bureaucracies in
the us and the uk
uh who kind of dithered around in
january february and
uh in the case of the u.s made no
successful effort to
increase testing actually the cdc
centers for disease control and
prevention made it harder to get a test
not not easier
well actually that reminds me of
something else that i think is relevant
to that which you pointed out that maybe
having looked at the public health
systems of
taiwan or south korea or other places in
east asia
might have given a very important object
lesson of course the fact that most of
what was going on there wasn't going on
on in english was perhaps relevant
remember i recently actually talked to
malcolm gladwell who's published a book
actually about the history of bombing
and the
ethical lessons from that in the second
world war but one of the almost sort of
observations he made in passing was that
certain scientific discoveries relevant
to world war ii bombing by the americans
were not noticed by them because they'd
only be published in japanese well
actually not even japanese by japanese
scholars
in esperanto which i'm pretty we know
was oddly enough quite common in early
20th century japan for reasons we
we won't go into uh to here but the
point remains that there's an awful lot
of information and knowledge out there
but not all of it is easily accessible
from the point of view of say
anglophones in north america and that's
very good example for globalizing
history
and applying global history as well it
is although it must be said that if one
looks in
to the major scientific disciplines that
are relevant
to a problem like uh a pandemic
to a far greater extent than was true
even 20 years ago and certainly to a far
greater extent than in the 1930s and
1940s they are in english i mean
the literature that was coming out of
wuhan uh in the very early stages of the
covert 19 pandemic uh was in english
because
chinese scientists have long been
accustomed to publish their
their pre-prints uh in english so so i i
can't offer that excuse to the people
in in key positions at the beginning of
2020 who
who i think flunked this quite badly but
you're right to raise the question of
how do we learn from history because
that's certainly the motivation behind
writing this book
i wanted to write a book that that dealt
with disaster as a
general category a phenomenon that can
come in
in all kinds of different shapes and
sizes because we have i think developed
a tendency to focus excessively narrowly
on just one or two scenarios that we
find appealing
so we're very fascinated as a species
right now
or at least the elites of uh of humanity
are with the prospect of disastrous
man-made climate change
and uh enormous amounts of uh of
hot air are emitted by people talking
about this problem
uh but it's only one of a wide range of
disasters that can
conceivably befall us and it might not
necessarily be the
the most clear and present danger
because as we saw last year
novel pathogen can move a lot more
rapidly than
climate change and there are other
things which we aren't paying much
attention to
uh which could be just as catastrophic
and again
faster acting and i'll throw out one
example of of
the kind of disaster we don't think
about nearly enough
that if we had the kind of volcanic
activity that the world had from the
late 1100s
to the late 1200s or even right through
until about 1815 which was the last
huge eruption uh mount tambora then we
very quickly would be having a
conversation about global cooling
uh so enormous the of the the effect
would be
it's just that recently and i'm talking
about for the last couple of hundred
years
there haven't been really big volcanic
eruptions and so we've kind of forgotten
that they can happen
uh and you know one could make a similar
argument about changes in sunspot
activity
so i conclude the book by trying to
offer a much larger menu
of potential disasters that we should
think about
because i fear that we might spend a
great deal of effort
on one disaster and end up being given a
completely different one to deal with
so one of the ways in which you use this
wider category of catastrophe
is to look at some longer-range
historical phenomenon i want to pick up
on one that we've mentioned a couple of
times before when he said actually now
that uh just now that
a lot of the first scientific research
uh coming out of warhan
in china was actually in english i point
out that from reliable sources there are
other areas of chinese research possibly
in artificial intelligence which are
possibly in chinese only and
restricted to certain readers but we
will possibly get that get back to the
the present day aspects of that in just
a moment
china's rise is something that you've
written about on various occasions you
know you have been teaching at ching hwa
university in china
in in recent years and you bring it up
in this book as well in a variety of
different contexts
i mean could i ask a mischievous
question which is is
the rise of china in the modern world
a catastrophe not in itself
that's to say the reduction of poverty
the growth of the chinese economy
all of these things are by themselves
good nobody wants china to be trapped in
the kind of poverty that characterized
it
in the 19th and 20th centuries the
problem is the rise of
china under the chinese communist party
is i think
a potentially disastrous outcome uh
because
it's not a disaster's outcome for the
chinese communist party or the millions
of people they rule out
well that remains to be seen because one
of the things about communist parties if
one just
learns from history is that they have a
very bad habit of inflicting disastrous
mortality on their own peoples
periodically in that that that of course
uh is the same chinese communist party
we're talking about that inflicted the
biggest man-made famine of them all
during the great leap forward that
inflicted the cultural revolution
on its own on its own people in the late
1960s and and so one has to remember
that
if if a totalitarian regime has a good
run
uh in raising uh living standards which
this one certainly has
that that doesn't protect its people uh
from that party
uh put committing future disastrous
mistakes because the party's entirely
unaccountable it is
functionally above the law uh and it has
no uh opposition it cannot be criticized
and as you know uh rana since xi jinping
came to power
the clock has been turned back in many
ways in china
not least in the universities where the
relative freedom i first encountered
when i started
traveling to china has really gone and
uh there's a great deal
uh more of that old chill in the air
that i remember
uh from my visits to to the soviet union
the thing things have become a great
deal more ideological
more explicitly anti-western uh this is
a regime that is essentially telling
schools
no more books that extol the virtues of
foreign systems
from now on you'll study xi jinping's
speeches
uh and i think we we are a little bit
reluctant in the west to recognize just
how much
china has changed and for the worse
under xi jinping
so it answers your question the rise of
the ccp led
china poses a potential threat to
china's
own population i don't rule that out
but it also poses a threat to everybody
else because as china expands
it's reached technologically and
economically it's able to exert pressure
on the free societies of the world
uh in all kinds of ways that uh are
perhaps more obvious
right now in australia than they are in
the uk but i think are relevant uh to
everybody
one of the big takeaways of the book is
that totalitarianism is a very bad thing
it caused some of the highest levels of
excess mortality
in the 20th century whether it was
stalin's version
uh mao's version or for that matter
hitler's and we shouldn't be happy
to see the growing power of a one-party
state
even if it says oh we won't do that kind
of thing again because what happened
let's remember what happened in in
december
of 2019 january of 2020. it was like a
vast chernobyl in the sense that a
disaster occurred
and the immediate response of the ccp at
the local and the national level was to
cover it up
and to deny that this problem was real
to tell the world health organization no
there's no human to human transmission
and only when it was too late uh when
the genie was at the bottle and the
virus was everywhere did they finally
acknowledge what had gone wrong
that's not a great advertisement for
this system i think no fair enough and i
don't think anyone certainly not me is
advertising the
uh putting forward positive advertising
for the system but i want to just push
back
a little bit against one of the analyses
in your book again drawing if i may on
on your own work
and what we're doing again just a
reminder to everyone i see some
questions coming in and we're going to
turn to q a
in just a moment or two but please do
keep more of them coming in
and please do make sure that you are
tweeting away on
iq2 so let's talk briefly about the
historical uh
context of the belt and road initiative
which uh you point out and others here
may well know is this sort of very large
projected idea which brings together
economics and geopolitics the idea that
china is going to be
sponsoring through huge amounts of debt
for other countries essentially
uh the building of bridges but also uh
you know
power stations but also of course the
new tech infrastructure which is going
to underpin
5g the internet of things and the
new cyber enabled world that we're uh
we're moving into
and you characterize this in terms of
empire something which you've written
about you know more than once previously
and obviously
um it's it's a model that's that's very
um
persuasive in terms of thinking about
what china's doing
but let me give you perhaps a less
apocalyptic vision
of how over time comparing
what china's doing now might make us a
little bit
less nervous than we might be in the
western world
but first of all this type of empire
that china's putting forward doesn't
seem really like a kind of classic
empire
on the grounds actually it's lots of
different private enterprises sort of
bumping up against each other sometimes
succeeding sometimes failing
you know even the debt traps which
people talk about are often happening
because actually the chinese thought
they were onto a good investment which
turns out in the end surprise surprise
to be a rather rather bad one the amount
of lending that china has done under
that initiative actually really
plummeted in the last year or two as
they found themselves really
not in a position to spread too much
largesse at all they've largely moved
towards actually
sending out vaccines and putting forward
a um
kind of uh intentions about potentially
enabling people's cyber capacity in
future years
in other words if this is an attempt to
build a global empire
it's actually a pretty ropey one isn't
it well
empires are always a bit ropey when you
study them up close and
the description you you've just given of
chinese expansion reminds me vividly of
the early stages of
of british expansion that sort of
strange combination of
of competing private agencies and then
the bad debt problem that you weren't
quite expecting
but i don't think the belt and road
initiative or one belt one road as it's
sometimes called is really the
the biggest worry that china poses
uh our our friend and uh a student like
fryman has written a terrific book on
this which shows that really
this is as much propaganda as it is a
grand design for world
domination but i when i look at other
aspects of
of china's expansion and uh and also
the tone of the the new wolf warrior
diplomacy
uh i i find myself a great deal less
uh easy in my mind first of all china
has a capacity thanks to its
development of artificial intelligence
and the expansion of its payment
platforms
to extend its model of surveillance
beyond its
its borders and the fact that the smart
city technology based on facial
recognition is now being available
is being made available in in dozens of
countries around the world
should i think give us pause in fact i i
think that is a more
serious uh risk than one belt one road
infrastructure projects uh financed in
ways that turn out to have been somewhat
imprudent
uh so yeah i think i think one one's
thinking about future challenges and
future dangers
the way i put it is this that china is
certainly expanding in empire-like ways
uh it is also clearly a much more
serious competitor
technologically than the soviet union
was particularly when it comes to
information
technology and the vision of a
surveillance state which
orwell had in 1984 is far closer to
being realized
in xi jinping's china than it ever was
uh
under mao or stalin because the
technology really does
allow the party if it wishes to monitor
citizens
uh everyday lives every day transactions
now that in itself uh is not a reason to
expect
at the end of the world we're not doomed
because of the rise of china
but we will be in a very difficult
position if the superpower rivalry that
we currently see which i think merits
the name cold war
ii escalates into hot war and that's
really
the scenario which i i worry about a lot
because it seems to me that a lot of the
ingredients are now in place
for a superpower conflict in asia
that will come as as as much of a
surprise as as
the korean war did in 1950 so i i end
the book by offering reflections on
the way in which things could blow up
over taiwan uh
in in a relatively near time frame and
after all
wars historically are second only to
pandemics when it comes to causing
really large amounts of premature death
so that's something i think we should
worry about a lot more
and of course it's worth remembering
that china did fight a war previously
about taiwan but it was in 1895 with
japan on that occasion the japanese won
in slightly different circumstances
i see we've got a whole variety of
questions coming in uh
based on your ideas neil so i will start
putting those to you
this one relates to where you're sitting
right now and as i say we're crossing
our fingers that the catastrophic
earthquake that you talked about doesn't
uh hit any time soon but
the question comes to you neil you
mentioned this will inevitably happen at
some point on the west coast then yet
there's no mass flight from california
is that
not our question asks a sign of
remarkable resilience and bargaining
an indication that we do all know that
catastrophe
is part of life and essentially it's
part of life that we're actually okay
with
yeah that's a great question in a way
that's that's one of the themes of
the book that we we have to live with
this
thought of impending doom and i give the
example of the british soldiers on the
western front in the first world war
singing the bells of hell go tingling
for you but not for me
uh a song which when i first heard it
struck me as as fascinating because it
gives you an insight into the way that
that young men think about the very real
danger that they all faced
i mean basically people underestimate
the risk that it will happen to them
and one saw that again actually during
the pandemic
we have to think in that way i think in
order not to be crippled by anxiety
and if you if you're living in close
proximity to a fault line
you can't really uh jump at every
uh every tremor because you will very
quickly find your life as miserable it's
a little bit like during the cold war
we we knew that there was a risk of
thermonuclear war but we didn't live our
lives with that
thought prominently in our minds uh and
i think that's part of the coping
strategy of being human on the
other hand uh when you look at the
probabilities
of geological disaster uh in parts of
asia indonesia for example in japan
i think it's different and i think one
conceived one considers the japanese
history
a much more intense preoccupation with
what you'll do
in case of of an earthquake or a tsunami
than we have here we've only just
this week rolled out a proper
california-wide
alert system only this week that would
actually let people get on their phones
an earthquake warning
and that tells you that we're not really
as focused on this
as we as we ought to be earthquakes
for some reason and this is one of the
mysteries of humanity
fault lines seem to attract us we love
to build our cities on them
a map of the world with fault lines and
conurbations would make you think that
human beings enjoyed earthquakes and
were drawn towards tsunamis
so i think this is one of the puzzles my
sense now i've lived here for four years
is that we're all a little bit in denial
about this and nobody truly has
a coherent uh game plan for the big one
and we could see that when the wildfires
became much much worse
last year i i did not see a society that
had a realistic risk assessment
of the danger of wildfire on the
contrary the californians have been in
denial about this problem for
the last 20 years and i'm afraid it's
only going to be getting worse because
nobody has a solution
well i wonder if that leads us rather
nicely into the question that's just
come in from christopher
uh and he asks he says hello neil what
do you see
as the three greatest dangers in the
modern world apart from climate change
so it's rather specific on that i've
always loved taking notes for the state
department or something
and do you think that too much effort is
being directed towards
climate action of those those dangers
what's your thoughts about that that's a
great question christopher i
do think that we are focusing too much
resources and attention on the climate
change risk that's not because i'm a
denier
i think there are very obvious dangers
and that the probability of the worst
case scenario
uh that the international planet climate
change envisaged has gone up
not down by the way one reason the risk
is going up is that for all their fine
words the chinese continue to build coal
burning
power stations at a terrific clip did
you know that 48
of the increase in co2 emissions in the
last well since paris
are due to to uh to china and china
alone
so i think this is a problem but it's
not the only problem and it's a
relatively slow acting problem as bjorn
nomberg
argued in his his most recent book
compared with some of the other things
that could conceivably go wrong now i've
already mentioned
that a u.s china war would be a whole
different ballgame from
war in iraq or war in afghanistan we've
forgotten
what great power conflict can look like
and if you want a sense of
what it might look like jim stavridis
has recently published a novel based on
his
uh extensive knowledge as uh as a former
admiral
uh in the u.s navy uh 2034.
uh so that would be my number one risk
let's
not forget what a really big war could
do
uh number two which is kind of a subset
of this
would be full-blown uh cyber warfare
causing an outage of the internet we are
now
heavily heavily reliant on this
technology that we're using right now
for this conversation
full-blown outage would plunge our
systems into chaos
uh even if if there was no other war
going on
uh and cyber warfare is already underway
on a very
fairly low level it's a sort of
permanent state almost hobbesian
state of conflict but if it were to
escalate in such a way that critical
infrastructure was disrupted
i don't like to think how u.s society
would cope with that
i'm very doubtful that we would prove uh
resilient in the face of that kind of
catastrophe and
i'll i'll throw in just for fun the
super volcano scenario because
nobody thinks about that but actually
spending a year in montana which i did
to get away from
not only the pandemic but the crazy
regulations they introduced in
california
was a good reminder because the
yellowstone super volcano was one of the
most
cataclysmic uh events of the distant
past something like that would
completely
transform our sense of of the climate
risk
and i i do think that we talk about
man-made climate changes if it's the
only sort that really matters
but historically uh we've seen periods
of uh
of of abnormal cold in the wake of
massive
volcanic eruptions we've forgotten that
that can happen i can't think of a
single reason why that couldn't happen
in the relatively near future we've just
had a quiet 200 years
but would the point be neil not that
it's the only type of climate change
that could happen but it's the only type
man-made is that all human-made
is the only type that we can actually do
anything very much about
yeah but i mean i think that if if
you're asking me what are the things
that we should be
thinking about other than man-made
climate change that the list is
is quite a a long one and i i think
that's part of the point of doom
uh to point out that if you're very very
well prepared for
one particular form of disaster you
shouldn't be surprised if history slaps
you in the face
with a completely different disaster you
almost never get the disaster you're
well
prepared for that's that's the lesson i
think of of a succession of presidencies
that i
i i review towards the end of the book
uh because i think that that's
the inherent problem of the way that we
think about
problems we tend to focus on the last
one i noticed last year that
many many policy makers uh responded to
the aftermath of the the onset of the
pandemic because if it was a financial
crisis
and used the same tools that had been
deployed after 2008
and that was a kind of category error in
many ways because
clearly a pandemic's not a financial
crisis it's very very tempting
both in military and civilian affairs to
want to fight the last war
or to fight the war that you've spent a
lot of time preparing for
and history is just not kind that way in
fact history seems to quite like
playing the trick on us of giving us a
disaster that we really didn't think
that much about until it happened
well that actually um i think leads into
well a couple of questions which i'm
going to bring together because they're
on on a similar
topic but they get to an aspect of what
you've just said neil which is
the way in which you know governing
parties
governments can use catastrophe as a
means of
forwarding their own nationalistic aims
uh i mean
we've talked about china before it's
also i think fair to say that plenty of
countries around the world are using
their covet response
as a way of defining themselves until
recently india was portraying itself as
someone that had done very well and this
had
reflected better on the society now of
course it's put itself into
into reverse mode on that do you think
that we're going to see an era of
political
opportunism which essentially draws on
capacit
the capacity to deal with catastrophe as
a way of defining the polity
well maybe i think politicians showed
themselves
by and large to be rather inept in
if if they try to instrumentalize uh the
crisis last year it usually blew up in
their faces so
those who wanted to cast themselves as
wartime leaders very quickly turned out
to be doing
about the worst you would have thought
that a pandemic that originated in china
and strongly argued for border controls
would have helped
donald trump i mean in a way it played
to his populist agenda uh but he
completely screwed up
uh his handling of it and by putting
himself front and center
uh of the uh us government response and
then and then
bundling it so i think the attempt to
instrumentalize the crisis
has generally led to to failure but what
i think is true
is that lower down the chain of command
for those
people whose whose lives really revolve
around devising regulations and then
imposing them on people it's been a
terrific opportunity now i think there
is a
a really important theme in the book
that we haven't touched on which is that
the point of failure is often in middle
management rather than at the top
that it's actually the bureaucracy
rather than the commander-in-chief that
can bundle things
i think it's also true that the
bureaucracy in many countries has seized
the opportunity presented by the
pandemic to extend its power
in all kinds of different ways and one
sees this in almost
trivial forms in california which has
a one-party system of its own because
the democrats have been dominant for so
long
the kind of mentality that i was struck
by
was the one that introduces regulations
even when there's no scientific basis
for them at all
there was a moment when they closed the
the parks and beaches here last year
which i found completely bizarre since
there was a single reason to think
that covert spread outdoors almost all
the research coming out of
the early phase of the pandemic showed
that it was spread indoors
and therefore to close the parks and
beaches just seemed potty but there they
were
officials were going to california
beaches there was one man who stopped
from paddle boarding in the middle of
the pacific ocean uh because of uh of
covert
so i think the real winners here have
been
that the petty regulators who've had a
field day
it reminds me a little bit of the you
know the air raid wardens
uh who were satirized in bbc's dad's
army you can remember the
insufferable man who was constantly
telling people
uh to to pull their curtains and those
people have had a terrific opportunity
to exercise power and they're still
doing it even when it's clear that
most of the regulations that remain
remain here are kind of superfluous
well the dad's army phrase of course is
don't you know there's a war on so you
could say
there's a there's a pandemic absolutely
just to take that point for a moment
about middle management i mean
you've expressed in terms of where we
are now with the pandemic do you think
that operates historically as well
looking at the past disasters over the
last you know 200 years or so as modern
governments develop
is there always that sort of
bureaucratic layer that essentially
messes up what's happening from from the
top or is it something peculiar to
this current crisis to do with disease
science and so forth
i think if you compare us with the 1950s
uh
we we have become more bureaucratic and
the the striking thing to me when i look
at the uh
the pandemics of the 1950s is the
nimbleness of the the government's
response
uh that cdc in the us was of relatively
recent origin in 1957
there wasn't an enormous sprawling
department of health and human services
as there is today
and yet when you look at what the advice
was that the public health officials
gave eisenhower it was
it was remarkably uh pragmatic
and clear-headed and my sense is that in
the us at least and it may be true of
the uk
and i'm sure if dominic cummings uh were
here he
he'd say it is that there has been a
decline in the competence
of of government and that's a view that
francis fukuyama
has has put forward too so i'm not alone
in making this
case uh mark andreessen talked about it
uh during the pandemic there's a
hideous word claudiocracy that somebody
coined to capture
the ways in which uh the so-called
administrative
state deals with uh the the risk of
disaster and then bungles the disaster
when it happens i'll i'll throw out one
anecdote just to illustrate the point uh
that there was and indeed is
uh an under secretary or is it a deputy
secretary for pandemic
preparedness in the department of health
and human services it's his one
job uh and one of the mysteries to me of
last year was where he was because he
was almost completely
missing in action and i delved into uh
the the role of of robert uh cadillac
and found a wonderful
lecture that he'd given in 2018 in texas
uh in which he reflected that if uh if
we really didn't prepare a bit better
for a pandemic
we'd be sol but i didn't know what sol
stood for
it's a u.s military speak for [ __ ] out
of luck
and this was the guy whose one job it
was to prepare
for a pandemic there are 36 page-long
pandemic preparedness plans
ultimately there are there's almost a
countless amount of
of paperwork on this it's just that none
of it worked and that's the thing that
interests me
clearly not the bureaucracy's private uh
finest hour but just to go back to the
1950s for a second
between then and now one could perhaps
argue the other way that
over the last 60 years or so that same
health and human
services behemoth has also been
responsible for one of the biggest
changes that's improved people's
standard of life which is stopping
people
smoking it's something done through
regulation it's done off the back of
research which is mostly paid for by the
state by people like the brits or
richard dole on the grounds that private
enterprise didn't want to pay for things
that would reduce
profits so smoking and people dying in
their millions from smoking was also a
catastrophe over years
isn't that that's the example of how the
bureaucracy can also get it right
oh i think that's clear and one of the
striking stories that i
i tell in the book is is all the kind of
imperceptible not necessarily much
celebrated improvements in public health
uh that long predated the campaign
against
uh tobacco going all the way back to the
the improvements in in basic hygiene in
in british cities that can be
traced from the victorian period uh it
was actually improvements in
in basic hygiene that that did a lot of
the reduction of
uh of mortality and the extension of
life expectancy more
really the great scientific medical
breakthroughs that we tend to
to make much more of so i don't disagree
with that my point is
is generally not specifically about
uh public health but generally about
about bureaucracy
what i think has evolved and it's really
from let's say the 1970s
is a somewhat legalistic state of mind
in which
if there is some probability uh
greater than zero of a particular uh
negative adverse outcome you need to
have at least a 36
page document spelling out a whole
series
of measures to be taken preemptively or
in response
great detailed regulation that doesn't
work when the crisis happens
think of all those pages of regulation
of bank capital
uh back in the 2000's the basel uh rules
and back capital adequacy which proved
utterly useless uh when the financial
crisis struck in 2008. so i don't think
this is a peculiar problem of public
health actually public health has
achieved a great many victories uh over
the last century
but more recently i think we've seen a
major failure of public health
bureaucracies
and i think it's because the legalistic
bureaucratic mindset has come into that
world
from other domains for the media it's
much easier to say
was all the fault of boris it was all
the fault of trump that that's been a
recurrent narrative over the past year
but i think that gets us away from the
real problem which is a rather more
profound one and actually rather harder
to fix i mean you can replace a
president we did
but you can't overnight transform the
culture
of a bureaucracy like cdc which very
clearly failed for reasons that had
nothing to do with trump
i'm going to squeeze in a couple more
questions here which are almost sort of
opposite sides of the same questions
i'll put them both to you uh neil
one of our questions is asked without
the internet could we have had lockdown
in 2020 well i guess we could have had
lockdown but it wouldn't have been quite
the same sort of
lockdown and the other question is what
role does 24-hour news have on the way
that people react and therefore
politicians respond
is this why compared to the 1950s it was
unpoliticized then and politicized now
and that relates of course to your wider
questions about networks and information
so two great questions i know we're
running short of time so i'll have to
give
brief answers yeah it made a huge
difference we couldn't have done the
lockdowns in the 1950s even if
the asian flu had been far worse because
hardly anybody could work from home in
those days whereas
uh if you look at nick bloom's work
terrific
british economist at stanford about a
third of all jobs in the us
can be done just as well 100
as well at home as in the office and
that's because the internet
and therefore i think lockdowns were
possible in 2020 in a way they never
really had been before
and that's important because their
possibility tempted us
to do them without really doing that
good a cost-benefit analysis
of the downsides of of what we were
doing on the second question i don't
think it's just that it's 24
7. the problem is the way in which news
has been polarized
and in particular the ways in which news
has shifted
onto the internet and become a domain
uh for clickbait remember that the
primary objective of the network
platforms
is to get your attention and retain it
for long enough
that you see ads the thing that does
that is sensational stories that don't
necessarily have to be true
and what what i wrote about in the
square in the tarot book that you and i
discussed around a couple of years ago
has turned out to be pretty prescient
that if you leave that
status quo if you allow news to become
part of this highly polarized
public sphere in which the primary
motivation of the
platforms is to sell ads and engage
eyeballs you're going to get a lot of
crazy stuff
uh crazy stuff about the virus crazy
stuff about
remedies and crazy stuff about vaccines
that's done
tremendous harm so it's not the amount
of news
i think it's the way in which the news
has become polarized and polluted with
fake news
thanks very much indeed neil we're
beginning to get to town so i'll throw
one last one
in for you for a brief answer and i'll
combine it actually
with it with with the thought that i had
about the book as well the question
comes in
uh saying thank you for a fascinating
and terrifying
expose so what grounds do we have for
any optimism or is there truly bleak
outlook for us all and i would point it
out as i throw that back to you for a
last thought neil that in your book you
do say
at least you think that the likelihood
of an alien invasion from space
is a relatively small likelihood so is
that the best you can offer us in terms
of bleakness or is there anything
i want to be clear that doom is a
slightly ironical title
uh inspired by you'll remember private
fraser we're doomed
uh in fact we're not doomed the
probability of of complete extinction is
is is a lot lower than you'd think from
reading science fiction just as the
probability of an alien invasion is
really low because the distances seem
overwhelmingly
large and the probability of their being
aggressive intelligent life doesn't seem
to me to be that high at least not
within striking distance of earth
so it's actually an optimistic book i
found it cheering to write this book
because it reminded me that this really
wasn't
by any means the worst disaster that
mankind has confronted
and it certainly wasn't likely to be an
extinction level
event i mean 0.04 percent of the world's
population
is a terrible tragedy when you express
it as 3 million lives
but in the great scheme of human history
uh it is not really anything close to
an extinction level event we survive
we survive and the majority of us
survive the majority of people on the
western front
in world war one survived it was only a
minority
of those uh tommy's for whom the bells
of hell really did
go dinga lingaling and so it's actually
contrary to what you might
expect from the title it's it's a
cheering book that reminds you that at
the end of it all most of us
are fine and life goes on and and as you
pointed out around
we quite often forget the disasters i
wouldn't be at all surprised if 100
years
from now this wasn't uh a major
topic in the history books uh in the
same way that the 5758 pandemic has
entirely vanished without trace
i can just expect it will be filmed soon
neil under the title it's a wonderful
life too judging by the way that you've
characterized it there regardless of
what you think
of the title it is a fascinating read
i'd like to thank neil ferguson very
much for being with us here
i'd like to thank all of you from around
the world the audience who have come to
us for this event
i'd like to thank intelligence squared
for organizing yet another fantastic
event